it's not just Brett Kavanaugh the media
is going after it's anyone who dares to
question his accusers credibility in the
end the all white and all male members
of the jury committee attacked Anita
Hills credibility and Thomas went on to
be narrowly confirmed 52 to 48 but there
was a political backlash the next year
in 1992 was called the year of the woman
as a record 24 women were elected to the
house and four women joined to others in
the Senate joining me now with reaction
is Mercedes slap White House director of
strategic communications Mercedes thanks
for coming in tonight's so great of you
to be here all right this is completely
wild even of course heard what we just
talked about but we now have senator
Blumenthal coming out saying the
following I want you to react
I think the nomination should be
withdrawn the bar here is not whether
you have not criminally assaulted
someone its credibility trust integrity
this nomination will not only cast a
shadow over judge Kavanaugh if he were
ever to be confirmed it will also stain
the United States Supreme Court
irreparably Mercedes this is the most
predictable playbook for the Democrats
the Democrats from day one has said that
they are not going to be supporting
Kavanagh for for a very long period of
time they were refusing to take meetings
with him and then they wait at the last
minute for senator Feinstein to come up
with this letter from this accuser on
Brett Kavanaugh after we've seen 32
hours of testimony by Judge Cavanaugh
after they've had close committing
hearings and after they've given him
over a thousand written questions and
what are we seeing Laura we're seeing
the fact that none of this from regards
to this accusation being made was
brought up to the attention of Judge
Kavanagh and so it's very clear that it
is did the politics and the delay
tactics that the Democrats keep pushing
forward and this is just one more
example coming from senator Blumenthal
not allowing this to be resolved in the
sunset as we know judge Kavanagh has
been very consistent in saying I
categorically deny this horrific idea
Blumenthal and and others like him do
you think they're really up at night
worried about Christine blase Ford are
they is this what they're motivated by
protecting women I mean what the
Democrats are worried about is the fact
that they know that this is that Judge
Cavanaugh is incredibly qualified to be
on thorough versus wait isn't it that's
the remind it's not just only Roe vs.
Wade but it's the fact that he is going
to be that strict constitutionalist said
he is the one that's going to interpret
the law follow precedent and and this
idea that they feel like they're losing
this battle and I feel that that is just
unjust because we know Laura looking at
the fact that you've had individuals
from a variety of legal experts those
and legal community supporting judge
Cavanaugh knowing that he's well
respected in the legal circles and the
fact that they want to tear down his
reputation try to ruin his good name
while this man judge Cavanaugh said I am
ready to testify today we should have a
lot of a lot of conservatives think they
shouldn't have delayed this hearing at
all letter from the accusers attorney
tonight
Deborah Katz as the Judiciary Committee
has recognized and done before an FBI
investigation of the incident should be
the first step in addressing your
allegations a full investigation by law
enforcement officials will ensure that
the crucial facts and witnesses in this
matter are assessed in a non-partisan
manner that the committee is fully
informed she's not going to be
testifying on Monday only when an
investigation is conducted in under way
will the White House insist that this
hearing go forward on Monday look we are
going to allow the Senate Judiciary
Committee to make these decisions it is
in their hands with that being said
Judge Cavanaugh has said I will testify
I will testify public this is I this is
political now so what is the White
House's political reaction to what is
clearly a political move by the
Democrats and by by her attorney who is
a Democrat activist it is incredibly
disturbing that they keep stalling that
they keep waiting why do you think
they're doing that well I mean you know
why they're doing this they know that
that October first Supreme Court
convenes they don't want Brett Kavanaugh
to be confirmed it's very clear what
they're again like I mentioned what
their playbook here and the reality
is that when you have judge Cavanaugh
someone who is beloved determine who has
don't care they don't care I know and
he's someone with such high integrity
someone who I personally worked with I
mean Laura we were both single we were
both in an office together dealing with
judicial nominees he was professional
respectful to all women it goes on and
on but yet they are willing at the last
minute to throw something out there to
see if it sticks when they had over six
weeks to bring this up and that's what's
so disturbing that's why it's just it
gets to the point to realize that they
are trying to ruin judge County is the
White House prepared to insist to the
Senate or strongly recommend to the
Senate to go forward with this Monday
hearing or just a convener boat look at
the Senate Judiciary Committee we'll
need to make that decision we stand by
Judge Cavanaugh he is willing to testify
publicly privately however the Senate
deems fit to is transparent from now he
is forthcoming he wants we need to get
this done
Mercedes thank you for coming in tonight
we're gonna be watching very closely
over the next few days to see how this
all develops of Cavanaugh